alors aujourd'hui je vous parle de quoi
aujourd'hui je vous parle d'un nouveau
produit que j'ai à la main je suis en
train de filmer avec c'est l'instinct
360 flow c'est en fait un stabilisateur
pour smartphone mais pas n'importe
lequel stabilisateur pour smartphone
parce qu'il est léger il est pratique
qu'il vous suit vous voyez hop là je me
déplace il me suit directement c'est lui
qui me saoule comme un grand
stabilisation sur 3 axes tout vous
expliquer vous allez voir ce truc là
c'est pas n'importe lequel il est
intéressant vous avez tous savoir et
voir surtout pour les créateurs de
contenu est-ce que c'est un produit qui
est susceptible de vous intéresser ou
pas vous êtes prêt allez on y va et on y
va à fond c'est parti
[Musique]
mais avant toute chose avant de vous
parler de l'instinct 360 Flo et bien on
va commencer par l'ouvrir et faire un
unboxing donc on remonte un peu dans le
passé on remonte et après on revient là
c'est promis voici le Creator kit
insta360 flow creatorkit alors on va
faire un unboxing très rapide pour
regarder ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur de
la boîte et comment c'est fait je l'ai
pas encore ouvert je vous attendais ça
c'est très joli c'est déjà assez fin je
trouve c'est pas trop trop gros c'est
plutôt bien on a tout un côté où on voit
en transparence donc ça c'est cool et il
y a un côté qui est très joli j'aime
beaucoup ce genre de design là insta360
ça c'est plutôt sympa comment ça s'ouvre
ensuite ça ça tourne et ça ça tourne ah
ouais c'est facile en fait et ça vient
l'activer directement j'ai entendu le
bruit donc là ça veut dire qu'il est
activé donc pour l'éteindre j'ai qu'à
faire comme ça et je viens le poser en
bas et là il est éteint donc il est
facile pratiquer donc ça c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal fichu et l'attaque
hop ça vient de l'allumer ça vient de
l'activer donc ça c'est pour la base ok
voyons voir ensuite ce que j'ai à
l'intérieur ça commence à s'ouvre ah
comme ça sur le côté alors là j'ai un
petit guide d'utilisateur que je vais
retrouver surtout sur ma version à moi
en chinois et en anglais peut-être que
vous il y aura du français je ne sais
pas il me montre comment l'assemblée
comment l'installer comment l'ouvrir ça
on a déjà trouvé et comment venir tout
poser ok bon c'est assez simple ensuite
à l'intérieur ah c'est pas mal ça parce
que ça s'enlève c'est une petite
pochette de transport qui me permet
d'avoir mes accessoires avec moi et de
les déplacer ça c'est pratique ça c'est
très très pratique donc ça veut dire que
là je vais avoir ça où je vais venir
mettre mon smartphone
dessus je suppose ça c'est quoi c'est la
petite light ça qui est relié de l'autre
côté de voir ça c'est pour revenir
attacher là c'est je pense une
surpoignée à venir mettre dessus pour
avoir un peu plus de grippe à mon avis
donc ça c'est pas mal l'instruction des
infos ça c'est du cap de rechargement
très simple très pratique ça c'est du
type C Lightning pour venir se mettre
sur un iPhone et ça c'est de l'USB C
USB a ok et là j'ai du type C pour un
Android donc il y en a un peu pour tout
le monde et ensuite ici ça ça doit
probablement être un petit éclairage qui
vient se brancher en USB C directement
dessus la première chose c'est
l'installation c'est un des points forts
sur lequel est venu booster insta360 sur
son flow et bien c'est que ça s'installe
extrêmement rapidement vous avez deux
éléments vous avez cette partie là qui
vient entourer votre smartphone donc
vous prenez votre Smartphone vous le
mettez autour jusque là tout va bien
vous prenez ensuite votre instinct 360
flow on va appeler le flow vous prenez
le flow et ensuite le flow vous faites
quoi hop là vous ouvrez vous ouvrez tac
il est actionné vous avez juste à venir
prendre à poser à clipper et ça part
directement et en plus ce truc qui est
vachement bien ça marche que sur iOS
c'est-à-dire qu'il va venir reconnaître
que vous êtes dessus ils vous envoient
une notification
insta360 notifications que vous avez
directement là vous n'avez qu'à appuyer
dessus et vous partez directement et
vous filmez donc ça c'est extrêmement
rapide donc super facile d'utilisation
hyper pratique simple et efficace alors
bien évidemment sur iOS c'est encore
plus simple au niveau de l'application
mais vous l'avez également sur Android
le truc est vachement bien ici c'est que
vous avez une stabilisation sur 3 axes
ça veut dire que vous avez effectivement
3 axes qui vont vous permettre d'avoir
cette articulation et de faire que ça
bouge absolument pas ce qui permet de
donner à ce flot une super stabilisation
quel que soit les choses que vous allez
faire alors que vous marchiez que vous
courriez que vous vous déplaciez un peu
tous les côtés et bien c'est vachement
cool parce que ça ne bougera pas donc
par exemple comme moi là je suis en
skate c'est hyper smooth ça vous suit
c'est vachement pratique si vous êtes en
train de monter des escaliers ben ça va
absorber le mouvement comme on est ici
en plus sur un stabilisateur qui est
aimanté c'est plus pour les sportifs un
peu du quotidien c'est pas pour les très
grosses sportifs qui veulent faire des
choses hyper dingues comme avec une
action cam à ce moment là il y aura
d'autres produits chez insta360 qui sont
faits pour vous mais ce produit là il
est vachement bien parce que il est
hyper smooth il est hyper stabilisé il
est très cool et cette stabilisation sur
trois axes ça fonctionne
merveilleusement bien alors vous avez
différentes façons de venir l'utiliser
soit vous pouvez à la main comme ça
comme une poignée un peu standard et
vous vous déplacez vous marchez c'est
pratique vous avez également l'option
perche à selfie et ça c'est vachement
cool parce que vous allez prendre de la
hauteur alors prendre de la hauteur
c'est pratique vous pouvez également
venir l'incliner comme ça donc vous
pouvez le maintenir comme ça vous
l'inclinez c'est pratique et ce qui est
également pratique c'est vous pouvez
venir le rebaissez un tout petit peu
comme ça et ça vous donne un peu d'angle
ça vous casse un peu le poignet il y a
une position un peu plus naturelle qui
est extrêmement simple à venir utiliser
après si vous avez un côté un peu
créatif et comme moi vous faites du
skate et bien vous prenez l'affaire
selfie vous le prenez comme ça et vous
venez filmer vers le bas lorsque vous
vous baladez donc ça c'est aussi très
cool vous faites un peu du razmote en
ville donc le truc est très sympa et il
y a une dernière option et pas des
moindres qui est vachement cool c'est
que vous avez un petit trépied à
l'intérieur donc vous prenez vous venez
ouvrir comme ça là vous étirez tac tac
tac et vous venez le poser directement
donc là vous voyez typiquement je le
pose là là j'ai juste à me mettre en
face hop reconnaissance de mon visage et
là je peux me reculer je peux venir
balader autour il va venir me suivre il
va traquer mon visage directement donc
ça c'est vachement cool pour
effectivement venir animer des choses
alors je vous le dis également vous
faites un live et bien vous pouvez venir
faire un live directement avec le suivi
de votre visage avec du tracking
directement si vous voulez juste vous
filmer et avoir les mains libres et bien
vous pouvez le faire bref il y a plein
d'usages c'est extrêmement polyvalent
donc on voit qu'en fait ici on a un
stabilisateur à 360° qui vous donne
plein d'options pour la créativité et ça
une fois de plus c'est vachement bien
alors il y a un autre qui est super
important sur le deept track je vous dis
tout de suite c'est qu'en fait vous vous
dites OK et bien si quelqu'un passe
devant moi il va venir me perdre et ben
non il y a un truc à s'intelligent ici
ça veut dire qu'il va vous réidentifier
pour revenir vous suivre donc là vous me
voyez il y a le petit carré qui est
autour de ma tête qui définit
effectivement que je suis en deal track
et lorsque je me mets comme ça vous
voyez hop là il me perd hop là il me
retrouve voyez il me perd il met ce
petit carré au centre hop là je reviens
il me retrouve donc en fait c'est très
cool parce qu'il y a une
ré-identification qui permet qui me
suivent directement et une fois de plus
te distrike si je veux l'annuler
j'appuie sur la molette derrière hop là
là il y a plus de Dick track je peux
sortir il m'a perdu je réappuie juste
une fois derrière il relance le deept
track il me reconnaît vous voyez hop là
il me perd il me retrouve hop là il me
fait il me retrouve on peut faire une
chorégraphie pendant des heures c'est
très malin toi qui est vachement bien
c'est le suivi là on va passer derrière
l'escalier il va me perdre complètement
donc là il me perd complètement mais il
me garde en mémoire et quand je
réapparaît de l'autre côté il me
retrouve pour trouver le cadre autour de
ma tête comme ça il y a ce de 3.0 et ça
une fois de plus c'est vachement bien
donc là regardez le Deep track
directement sur un objet il le reconnaît
il reconnaît mon objet donc lorsque je
viens déplacer il vient se déplacer tout
seul très très facilement c'est
intelligent et lorsque je viens
complexifier un petit peu voyez il le
perd je reviens là il le récupère très
très facilement voyez hop là il le perd
je reviens il le retrouve là donc ça
c'est vachement bien ça marche bien
évidemment sur les humains mais sur les
objets et je trouve ça vachement fluide
parce qu'une fois de plus si vous voulez
suivre un objet alors là c'est un mug
mais vous pouvez le faire aussi avec une
voiture et ben c'est franchement une
fois de plus super bien en plus ici il y
a une option qui est à base
d'intelligence artificielle qui est très
cool qui s'appelle le shot génie en fait
qu'est-ce que va venir faire ici votre
flow et bien il va venir vous
recommander différentes techniques pour
venir à filmer en fonction de ce que lui
va capter Yahoo là il y a un truc je
vais lui proposer de filmer comme ça
cela va vous donner plus d'idées
créatives et venir élargir votre champ
des possibles et ça une fois de plus
intéressant pour utiliser le chute du
génie vous cliquez sur l'icône en haut à
gauche verte donc soit vous pouvez faire
une commande vocale et lui dire ce que
vous voulez soit vous cliquez sur
bibliothèque ce que je vous recommande
ici c'est quand même vachement plus
simple vous allez voir différents types
de scènes différents types de films que
vous pouvez créer alors là par exemple
c'est pour de la route d'or vous baladez
dans les bois on vous reprend face et si
et ça et en fait ça va vous n'hésitez
pas à pas pour vous montrer comment
venir créer les plans idéaux donc là
vous voyez par exemple pour de la
cuisine vous préparez Yassi Yasa en
extérieur au bord de la plage dans une
ville bref ça va vous prendre par la
main vous cliquez sur Je veux filmer et
là ça vous montre scène numéro 1 vous
filmez comme ça ensuite on continue
scène numéro 2 vous faites si vous
faites ça ça vous l'explique
complètement alors le truc qui est bien
c'est que ça vous prend par la main pour
venir créer des plans qui sont vachement
bien fait et très définis et pré écrit
par insta360 le truc un peu négatif
c'est que c'est écrit à la fois en
français en anglais par exemple ici les
champs de vision et en dessous bust shot
compétences de film et ensuite tout
écrit en anglais mais bon après si vous
comprenez l'anglais vous allez voir
c'est quand même vachement bien fait
après le logiciel est plutôt bien foutu
avec différentes possibilités vous avez
la capture panoramique à 360 degrés du
timelapse du Timeshift bref plein
d'options pour venir totalement
maximiser votre créativité
[Musique]
un gros point positif sur cette insta360
flow et bien c'est toute la commande que
vous allez avoir ici au travers de cette
molette alors en fait c'est une molette
sans être une molette je vous explique
comment ça va parce que c'est
extrêmement pratique alors déjà c'est
très simple très dégagé très visuel vous
voyez directement de quoi on parle là
vous avez différents modes auto fpfv en
fait automatique c'est un mode
automatique tout ce qui est plus
standard c'est automatique F1 mode de
suivi PF c'est un mode de suivi
automatique et FPV ça vient simuler
comme si vous aviez un drone en FPV avec
un côté un petit peu plus haut et vous
allez descendre des monter un peu tous
les côtés bref vous avez ces modes là et
pour venir switcher entre ces modes il y
a un côté qui est vachement pratique je
trouve ça très intuitif en fait vous
venez juste déplacer votre doigt faites
un petit tour là sur cet écran là vous
voyez hop vous venez de switcher donc là
vous faites un demi-tour comme ça hop et
vous le sentez sous votre doigt il y a
un côté un peu à petit qui a une
vibration et vous venez switcher
directement entre un mode et l'autre et
pour revenir sur un mode précédent vous
faites la même chose mais dans le sens
inverse vous posez votre doigt vous
tournez ça revient tac tac vous voyez je
reviens au mode avant donc ça c'est
quand même vachement du coup est très
très pratique et très intuitif alors
pour revenir sur le reste des boutons je
vous montre c'est très simple là vous
avez le bouton pour venir allumer
éteindre en fait vous laissez votre
doigt appuyer pendant quelques secondes
tac vous allez voir ça va redescendre
PAF il est éteint pour l'allumer c'est
la même chose vous appuyez vous laissez
votre doigt allumé tac tac votre game
boy ça positionne directement et c'est
très simple si vous voulez voir votre
niveau de batterie vous appuyez une fois
dessus ça vous montre votre niveau de
batterie là vous voyez je suis au 3/4 je
suis tranquille donc ça c'est plutôt
cool et si vous voulez vous mettre en
veille vous appuyez juste deux fois il
se met en veille comme ça vous avez qu'à
appuyé ensuite deux fois il revient
directement ça permet d'économiser un
petit peu sa batterie sans forcément
avoir à l'éteindre ça va dépendre d'une
fois de plus des usages et un instant T
alors on le voit ce petit point rouge
c'est le point pour venir filmer vous
appuyez dessus tac vous lancez
l'enregistrement vous rappuyez dessus
tant que vous coupez l'enregistrement
derrière je vais mettre un point un peu
plus large vous allez voir typiquement
je suis en train de me regarder si
j'appuie ici tac il vient lancer
l'enregistrement et si je rappuie une
fois il vient couper l'enregistrement
c'est très simple la même manière si je
veux passer sur le mode photo j'ai
appuyé trois fois ici je passe en mode
photo et j'ai qu'à appuyé sur ce bouton
là hop ça déclenche ma photo très
simplement vous voyez ça déclenche ça
prend des photos alors ça c'est une
fonctionnalité qu'on va voir avec Claude
bouton vous avez juste sur le côté ici
qui va permettre de venir switcher d'un
mode à l'autre donc là vous voyez
j'appuie trois fois sur le bouton là 1 2
3 et je repasse en mode vidéo alors ce
petit bouton là là à la base il sert pas
pour faire que ça il a d'autres
fonctions déjà vous allez appuyer une
seule fois dessus et vous allez voir que
ça vous permet de switcher entre la
caméra avant la caméra arrière donc là
je serai la caméra selfie j'appuie une
fois je passe sur la caméra arrière
voyez juste une fois je switch entre
l'avant et l'arrière si j'appuie deux
fois ça me fait pivoter mon smartphone
entre une position horizontale et une
position verticale ça dépend si vous
voulez venir filmer plus pour une vidéo
de VOD YouTube ou pour faire YouTube
shop j'appuie deux fois hop et ça vient
pivoter directement j'aurais pu deux
fois ça pivote dans l'autre sens bon
comme je suis là vous voyez c'est pas
très pratique mais en fait c'est ce
principe là hop j'appuie deux fois dans
ce sens là je rappuie deux fois dans ce
sens là et si je le mets face à vous
comme ça vous me voyez j'appuie deux
fois hop comme ça je rappuie deux fois
hop comme ça c'est pratique maintenant
je vais avoir cette petite molette là
alors cette molette là elle me servira à
venir piloter directement vous voyez mon
gimbal si je veux aller vers le bas vers
le haut je te fais avec un seul doigt
d'ailleurs avec mon seul pouce dans un
sens dans l'autre je vais le pivoter
très simplement voyez je redescends je
remonte je vais d'un côté je vais de
l'autre comme ça je peux tout voir et
vous voyez exactement tout ce qui se
passe ici dans le studio pratique donc
là j'ai cette zone de commande mais j'ai
également une petite molette sur le côté
qui me permet de venir zoomer
directement dans mon image je zoom et là
je dézoome et ça c'est vraiment très
très pratique parce que vous venez
zoomer directement alors uniquement
quand vous êtes sur la caméra arrière
pas sur la caméra avant ça ne marchera
pas mais voyez on vient zoomer
directement on va jusqu'à un zoom x 9
c'est le maximum et après je viens
dézoomer je vais switcher de mon
téléobjectif sur mon grand-angle et
ensuite je passerai directement sur mon
ultra grand-angle donc c'est très très
saoul ça c'est vraiment un truc très
cool on sent juste le saut d'objectif ça
c'est pas anormal une fois de plus mais
sinon ça reste quand même extrêmement
pratique et vous voyez là la même
manière je peux me dire zoomer
directement je zoome je zoome je zoom je
zoome je zoome je zoome je zoom je
dézoom je dézoome je dézoom je dézoom je
dézoom je dézoom je dézoom c'est très
pratique et en plus de ça vous avez une
petite gâchette qui est planqué juste
derrière ici alors cette gâchette elle
est intéressante pour trois trucs le
premier truc lorsque vous êtes comme ça
vous êtes pas sur le Deep tracking donc
on va pas venir me suivre donc lorsque
je me déplace voyez ça vient pas me
suivre j'appuie une fois hop ça lance ce
diptracking ça reconnait
une batterie vous savez où vous en êtes
vous êtes tranquille mais une journée
d'autonomie dans cette petite truc là
c'est quand même vachement bien alors la
question que je me pose c'est qui est
venu cibler un stade 360 ici avec ce
nouveau produit parce qu'ils ont une
gamme de produits qui est très large qui
va aller des sportifs les plus
chevronnés qui veulent des produits pour
la route d'or qui veulent notamment et
pourquoi pas de la caméra à 360 il y a
plein d'options il y a plein de produits
avec ce petit produit avec le flow ils
viennent plutôt chercher les créateurs
de contenu un peu comme moi qui veulent
de la modularité qui vont venir filmer
avec un smartphone et qui veulent pas
s'embêter qui veulent augmenter leur
qualité qui veulent une super
stabilisation ils veulent également
venir proposer un super outil aux
personnes qui veulent pas s'embêter qui
veulent venir streamer vous prenez votre
truc tac vous êtes dans un endroit un
peu comme ça vous voulez streamer les
mains libres pour montrer un produit
typiquement moi je suis sur un lancement
de produit je le prends je le pose il
reconnaît mon visage je vous montre des
produits je me déplace c'est vachement
bien pensé bien évidemment et je vous le
disais moi j'ai mon skate pour les
personnes qui veulent également pour
porter vlog ou pour les sportifs faire
du skate qui veulent pas s'embêter qui
veulent en stabilisateur qui est cool
pour votre smartphone une fois de plus
et que pour vos smartphones ils veulent
également cibler qui va les familles les
familles qui veulent partir en road trip
et qui veulent ramener des souvenirs de
vacances avec une superbe qualité qui
veulent faire un time la dedans qui
veulent shooter un coucher de soleil qui
veulent ramener des trucs de supercal il
était donc en fait c'est un outil je
dirais un peu à 360 pour tout le monde
n'est pas forcément pour tout le monde
pas pour les sportifs les plus
chevronnés parce qu'une fois de plus ici
on est aimanté donc si vous mettez des
grands coups et que ça bouge un moment
ça risque de s'en aller après le côté
pratique c'est que ça serait menthe très
facilement mais si vous avez pas envie
de perdre votre smartphone dans la
poudreuse et bien déconner pas il fait
pas de passage hop là je le prends je le
repose ça revient très rapidement mais
je vous le dis une fois de plus le
smartphone dans la poudreuse c'est pas
la bonne idée
[Musique]
une application qui vous permet de venir
piloter directement votre
insta360 flow alors c'est extrêmement
pratique parce que très très simple il y
a plein d'astuces de tous les côtés et
puis d'une façon un peu globale un Star
360 un bien vous prendre par la main
pour vous dire regardez ce que vous
pouvez venir faire regarder ce qui est
possible il y a énormément de
possibilités c'est très cool
l'application a le même pour venir
shooter et très simple et complètement
connecté automatiquement à votre flow
donc ça c'est cool ça se fait en
Bluetooth c'est très très pratique je
voulais montrer que ce soit pour le zoom
pour switcher sur la caméra avant
arrière et compagnie vous avez plein de
modes différents pour venir filmer vous
avez le mode photo vous avez le photo
panoramique vous allez également avoir
du ralenti vous allez avoir un mode
écran large vous avez également un
timelapse un Time Shift un mode Live le
mode Live est pas mal parce que lorsque
vous voulez venir alors soit faire du
live directement et streamer vous pouvez
venir l'utiliser ou si vous voulez
passer un coup de fil à partir d'une
application vidéo et bien vous pouvez le
faire directement ici avec le suivi de
votre visage donc vous posez votre flow
sur une table vous avez les mains libres
vous pouvez faire un appel visio
directement
en train de cuisiner par exemple si vous
avez de la main dans la pâte et bien
vous pouvez le faire c'est très très
cool alors au-delà de ces usages qui
vont être un petit peu plus nichés moi
ce qu'il y a bien m’intéresser c'est
tout ce qu'on pourra venir filmer ici
alors vous choisissez également votre
résolution ici sur mon iphone je peux
monter sur 4K à 60 vous avez ces
différentes résolutions ok vous avez des
petits réglages également au niveau de
la balance des blancs si ça vous pouvez
venir le passer en manuel moi je laisse
en automatique ça me va très très bien
également vous avez différents réglages
pour votre flow mode flow automatique
vitesse de la manette vitesse du zoom
sensibilité du suivi bref il y a pas mal
de petites possibilités et je trouve ça
très très cool on peut venir inverser le
joystick verticalement ou
horizontalement en fonction de son
habitude c'est très très cool également
et puis après vous retrouver sur une
appli vous avez quand même vachement de
choses ici ça c'est très très bien fait
plein de paramètres alors il y a un côté
un peu gamification chez insta360 je
sais pas si vous avez déjà des produits
de chez eux mais ils aiment bien
gamifier pour vous donner des petits
points des petits trucs comme ça il y a
toute une grosse côté communauté les
aides techniques là vous connectez votre
appareil je vois mon niveau de batterie
restant la version du firmware c'est la
dernière les informations sur la caméra
et puis après bon il y a plein de
petites options si ça vous intéresse et
regarder ce qui est très cool surtout
vous voyez c'est ce que fait plutôt bien
un stade 360 c'est que vous allez avoir
votre caméra qui va paraître en haut
alors au moment où moi je tourne cette
vidéo je suis sur une version bêta de la
vidéo la flo n'est pas officialisé donc
il la font pas paraître mais lorsque
vous regardez cette vidéo vous pourrez
voir la flo apparaître en haut et vous
donner un peu des idées de ce que vous
allez pouvoir venir shooter avec alors
là il me montre là c'est sur la X3 donc
ça raconte pas tout à fait la même
histoire mais bon ça vous donne des
idées ce que vous pouvez venir faire
très facilement venir shooter vous avez
également votre album avec les vidéos
que vous avez déjà fait vidéo et photos
vous avez une petite côté avec
différentes stories bref il y a pas mal
de possibilités de côté très
communautaire qui est quand même
vachement cool pour venir s'inspirer
venir prendre des bonnes idées donc ça
c'est bien une fois de plus vos réglages
et vous venez shooter en appuyant
directement ici au milieu et à notre
truc est vachement intéressant qui a
plutôt bien pensé ici insta360 et bien
c'était pour venir mettre des
accessoires parce que on se doute
lorsqu'on est créateurs de contenu on va
venir utiliser un micro des fois on a
besoin d'un petit renfort en éclairage
et bien ici vous avez tout directement
alors pour venir brancher un petit micro
de rode très facilement alors regardez
ça se passe ici juste au dos vous venez
lever cette partie là vous voyez qu'ici
ce côté transparent avec le branding
vous levez ça vous fait une petite
glissière pour venir poser hop là votre
micro notamment un petit micro drone
vous pouvez venir mettre là donc ça vous
fait le petit récepteur et vous avez
l'émetteur sur vous alors soit vous le
branchez directement à votre smartphone
pour envoyer le signal directement dans
votre smartPhone soit vous enregistrer
en interne et après vous venez tous
synchroniser après ça aussi très très
pratique moi c'est le premier truc au
niveau du son et puis fatalement il y a
un autre truc qui nous intéresse ici et
bien c'est le côté éclairage parce que
oui comme on est sur un gimbo des fois
on n'a pas toujours beaucoup de lumière
on a besoin d'un petit renfort de
lumière et bien ils ont pensé à ce petit
accessoire là qui est en fait un petit
éclairage qui vient légèrement bouger
vous voyez comme ça en fonction comment
vous avez bien le positionner et qui
vient se mettre directement ici donc je
trouve ça une fois de plus très malin ça
c'est vraiment l'endroit où vous venez
poser votre smartphone et en fait si
vous regardez derrière vous avez un
petit système de pince là en fait vous
appuyez ça ouvre légèrement vous venez
le positionner là ça se trouve très
facilement sa place et là sur le côté
vous avez l'USB C donc là tac vous
branchez ça vous envoie à du jus
directement et ce qui fait que lorsque
vous venez et que vous positionnez on va
l'allumer comme ça et bien vous allez
voir que ça vous envoie un éclairage
donc le truc est quand même pas mal
voyez ça éclaire quand même c'est pas
trop mal fichu ce bazar donc lorsque je
viens positionner ensuite mon smartphone
alors je vais le mettre en veille alors
là ça vient vous éclairer vous ça
n'éclaire pas moi mais si je reviens
comme ça et que je mets clairement et
bien voyez ça l'éclaire un petit peu
alors j'ai différents niveaux
d'intensité je vais vous le remettre
vers vous que j'ai des petits boutons
sur le dessus là hop je peux monter
l'intensité là je suis à fond et là ça
diminue donc là un niveau de niveau 3
niveaux et je redescends au plus bas
donc j'ai trois niveaux d'intensité pour
venir m'éclairer directement donc il y a
un côté pratique alors après je peux
venir tourner directement parce que si
j'utilise la caméra derrière et bien je
vais pouvoir lire m'éclairer directement
donc vous voyez donc là j'active du
tracking il me reconnaît la lumière
m'éclaire je peux choisir mon niveau
d'éclairage je trouve ça une fois de
plus très pratique du fait d'avoir ses
accessoires que ce soit pour la lumière
que ce soit pour le sombre c'est très
complet et ce qu'on voit ici c'est que
un sa 360 a pensé à tout et ça c'est
vachement bien et je vous donne une
astuce qui est extrêmement maligne
lorsque vous voulez venir filmer
directement et bien pour utiliser la
meilleure caméra vous utilisez la caméra
derrière donc fait un trois tapes 1 2 3
le téléphone va switcher et ensuite vous
relancer le dim tracking 3.0 vous mettez
devant vous appuyez une fois et là il
vous reconnaît il va vous suivre
regardez comme ça je peux me déplacer il
me suit et après j'ai plus qu'à appuyer
ici sur Enregistrer donc là je suis en
train d'enregistrer il va venir me
suivre c'est pratique je suis créatif
j'ai la meilleure caméra et je sais je
serai toujours dans le cadre ce produit
déjà il faut savoir qui sort le 29 donc
il sort très bientôt bon moi je suis en
train de tourner c'est quelques jours
avant donc si vous vous regardez cette
vidéo c'est qu'il est déjà sorti parce
que je sors la vidéo uniquement quand il
est sorti ça c'est pratique alors en
terme de tarif qu'est-ce que ça raconte
j'ai deux tarifs il y a deux package en
gros de base si vous achetez votre flow
vous l'avez au tarif de 169 € et dans le
package vous avez le flow vous avez la
pochette de protection vous avez la
pince magnétique bien évidemment pour
venir poser vos smartphones sans quoi
c'est pas marrant ils m'ont fait quelque
chose vous avez en plus le revêtement
pour la poignée le petit grip que vous
avez là qui est quand même indispensable
pour moi sinon ça glisse vous avez
également un câble de rechargement pour
venir le recharger lui en USB C vers de
l'usba de l'usba pour votre ordi et de
l'usb-c pour lui voilà un peu ça c'est
le package de base à 169 mais vous avez
également un kit créateur à 229 euros
alors vous allez retrouver tout ce que
vous avez dans le premier package qui
inclut c'est-à-dire le grip pour la
poignée le flow l'attache magn le câble
usb-c USBA et vous avez en plus de ça le
spotlight la petite lumière que vous
allez venir mettre sur le dessus parce
que comme on s'adresse au créateur de
contenu et bien on veut pouvoir
s'éclairer lorsque vous avez pas trop de
lumière donc vous avez ça en plus vous
avez également le sac de transport alors
vous l'avez vu l'unboxing mais je vous
le reprécise quand même vous avez en
plus un câble usb-c versus BC ça peut
être pratique pour le recharger si votre
ordinateur n'a pas du SVA mais à queue
du SBC et vous avez également un type C
vers du Lightning pour brancher votre
smartphone donc ça c'est pratique parce
qu'en plus il y a une option qui est là
pour venir recharger votre smartphone
directement à partir de votre flow et ça
une fois de plus c'est cool donc bon moi
je vais vous donner mon retour sur ce
flow ce flot je trouve que c'est un
accessoire très intéressant de petites
tailles compas qui se replient très
facilement et qu'on emmène facilement
avec soi donc ça c'est vraiment le gros
point positif de ce produit maintenant
si je dois lui reconnaître un seul
inconvénient parce que il n'a pas
énormément alors je vous dis déjà si
vous êtes un sportif chevronné que vous
voulez vous balader que ça bouge ça
saute et compagnie c'est pas forcément
la bonne idée parce que vous risquez que
la tâche magnétique se détache il y a
pas de protection il y a pas de lit ça
va se barrer c'est le bordel donc non on
va pas sauter des grands trucs on peut
faire du BMX avec non on va pas le faire
et pour monsieur madame tout le monde
qui veut venir se balader dans des
souvenirs et sauter une marche ça ira ça
stabiliser ça tiendra très très bien le
deuxième petit point un peu négatif que
je pourrais venir reprocher ici c'est
que cette poignée même si elle est
pratique avec le petit grip que vous
avez dessus qu'elle tient bien et bien
elle est plus faites pour les petites
mains moi regardez j'ai une petite main
donc là ça fonctionne bien mais vous
voyez sur le bal j'ai rien donc là
j'aurais bien voulu te mettre un poil
plus long pour avoir une meilleure
sensation de tenue alors attention ici
je le tiens bien j'ai pas l'impression
que ça tient mal je suis rassuré ça me
va bien ça fonctionne bien mais je pense
que si des personnes ont des trop
grosses mains fallait trop gros si vous
avez des mains un peu plus grosse en
tout cas que la mienne vous voyez ça
attaque de ma paluche regardez par
rapport à ma tête et bien un moment vous
risquez d'avoir un petit peu la surprise
de vous dire ah ouais mais en fait c'est
mini mini donc voilà ça c'est vraiment
le truc à venir connaitre alors si vous
voulez augmenter la taille de prise en
main on peut venir augmenter ça comme ça
pour avoir une sensation un peu plus un
peu plus longue à côté de ça comme on
est sur un côté trépied ça bouge un peu
c'est pas optimal mais si vous avez des
mains comme moi et que vous le prenez
comme ça il y a pas de souci ça tient
bien en main on trouve très facilement
sa position au niveau de ses doigts pour
venir le manipuler donc pour moi c'est
pas mauvais surprise donc je trouve 15 à
360 nous propose un produit super
intéressant si vous avez besoin d'un
stabilisateur pour smartphone avec
toutes les options et tous les horizons
que ça ouvre donc moi je trouve ça
chouette dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires est-ce que
c'est un produit qui pourrait vous
intéresser est-ce que ça vous aime ça
vous tente est-ce que vous recherchez un
produit comme celui-là et une fois de
plus si vous intéresse je vous mets le
lien juste en bas dans la description
d'ici là surtout les faire du skate donc
on va faire plein de plans avec je
m'amuser je vous embrasse prenez soin de
vous et à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]